if you look at the experience with
citizens initiative rights and member
states
you clearly see that if such tools are
to be workable they must be designed in
a citizen friendly way that is much more
challenging even on the european level
therefore we said keep even the
restrictions lower than on national
level and keep up the support so-called
support elements it's a great initiative
we're happy that it's there but it
hasn't really caught on
there's lots of reasons that have been
discussed
one that i would like to add here as
well is
has been a lot of communication about it
in the european parliament especially in
the sphere of communication we have very
strong values we are neutral we are
balanced we are accurate and we are
transparent that's few of our main
values that always builds the
communication of the open parliament we
stick to them even online it's not about
total openness now it's not about let's
open up everything and let's everyone
see every little um
part of our internal process there is
always room for
uh restricted workshop there is always
room for close collaboration what is
important is to gradually open up
citizens have finally realized that they
have much more power than they thought
and they are they decided to not be only
spectacular spectators or listeners or
voters they decided to raise up and to
lead the ma
the masses and to start making change by
themselves every month
we see 15 000 new petitions around the
world starting on change.org that means
hundreds of thousands of people
mobilizing behind issues but most
importantly that means
tens of victories every day around the
world and this is only the beginning
until this moment people only had to
reply to those few solutions but now the
challenge is to answer to all those huge
causes to all those huge movements
initiated by thousands or hundreds of
thousands of people every month around
the world
yeah emotions do we need them of course
we need them i mean if you've ever seen
i don't know mr khan bandit or mr nigel
farage it's important for them it
matters
we're talking about politician
and we try to reflect those emotions
when we kind of have it
um especially you know you know online
content in the interview in the chat
even you can see sometimes you have
spontaneous
amusement or anger at the question and
we try to convey it
and the dialogue on germany's future was
not just an internet-based operation it
was basically two-pronged and we were
overwhelmed by as a result especially
if you have 25 000 visits a day and
several
hundreds to thousands of comments or
proposals coming in a day
we had to expand our editorial team
considerably citizens want to
participate
there are new neighborhood movements uh
formed
via social media very strong very
very immediate very very new and in one
year we have seen like action like never
before in his helsinki city
on the grassroot level
in
may this year we opened the government
for citizens portal this is the one-stop
shop for citizens to access public
services uh again it's a very innovative
tool for for our country
we still um do not realize the potential
of the social media in terms of
listening to the citizens and engaging
in a dialogue with citizens i mean we
are we are posting what we do but we are
still we have still to learn how to
engage and how to make sense of all
these tools
we need to have a behind the type of
instruments that we use
uh the vision so the message that needs
to be conveyed and uh it may be one or
another type of policy but what uh what
uh lays behind is just the fact that
there must be a common will to to make
good things for citizens